it's been 15 years since we took our
first steps in Vardhan fell and I must
say it feels good to be back the Elder
Scrolls Online's latest update takes us
back 700 years before the events of the
classic 2002 game the Elder Scrolls 3
moorwen join us as we explore the
remastered world of more wind and speak
with some familiar faces from elder
scrolls past ESO morrowind will be
released globally on June the 6th so
consider hitting the subscribe button
for more elder scrolls news please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
ah
ah
I demand to see my brother lay hands
upon me and you will lose them you there
the territory of the red exile shouldn't
be traveled lightly Ashe Landers once
respected each other
helped one another you'd think these
were house wolves or tribe you old dogs
the way they treated me speaking of the
tribunal you have the smell of dog about
you I wonder why that is
Lord vivec is it and I thought all the
tribunal cared about was building
monuments to their own greatness nice to
see that one of them cares about what's
going on beyond their borders well
perhaps we can eat each other to stay
Outlander
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
love you too
this is ridiculous or my wife
[Music]
[Music]
well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
glad to bait the crystals look for pure
life or muddled I'll modulate the energy
fluctuations make sure nothing explodes
if color confounds who will look at the
shape fewest sides to most the great
gear turns so be quick quick good health
okay
you
[Music]
oh wow
I'm all together
[Music]
[Music]
ah
did you find what you were looking for
in the mind of course my perfectly
understand I think I wait a little
longer and see if any of my miners were
able to escape from the cultists good
luck with your mission whatever it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
North effect needs to do something look
at that slide those of us in receiving
visitors today
[Music]
my lord please let me send for eight
perhaps one of these yields can help you
and is best tolerated in private as I
have written in the pleasure 7 palette
there must be something I can do you can
call the arch cannon you should hear the
news our friend brings us the river
drains into the sea as my divinity flows
out of me need some work
as you can see I continue to lose energy
mit has made me somewhat agitated have
you made any progress toward discovering
the source of my discomfort an ash
ladder that seems unlikely
but I trust your instincts you need to
find out more about this true liver and
the ancient enemy that ate take this
another token of my appreciation and
look here comes the arch cannon now Lord
we hope either may have actually
discovered something
[Music]
Oh
[Music]